[Music]
so
hi how are you guys doing i just want to
welcome you guys to the table so
thrilled that each one of you guys are
here
um i want to welcome everyone who's here
in person
and of course our visitors online we're
thrilled that you're able to join us
here
too um so i just want to start as often
just recognize that it is pride month
[Laughter]
okay it's very good so it's pride month
[Applause]
and those of you who are joyous online i
know it's one of those kind of things
where
it's it's kind of interesting to be in a
church
and to talk about gay lgbtq pride
it's just kind of a it's still a very
strange
very weird um thing it's not normal
i'm just kind of just going to name that
that's just not a normal thing to do
it's not a normal thing
as a queer person to stand in front of
your church and to be
able to serve on leadership to be as out
as i
am to be able to discuss this as openly
and as those that's the most normal
thing face the planet
and so i just want to and i just want to
spend a minute just to kind of name that
um and just also recognize there are
many people who are watching
online or listening to the sound of my
voice that are in spaces
that can't find a church like this and
they are joining specifically online
because
this is the only place this is the only
places where they can hear affirming
voices
that that know where they are so that's
just it's just amazing
it's amazing okay couple quick
announcements
um moving on from that couple quick
announcements so
um so it is first um the first sunday of
the month
um to also go along with that so at the
end of our first
sunday or the end of this service i
should say uh we are going to be
getting together for like we did last
month
and we're meeting at hack creek bakery
the hat creek
burger thank you apparently i need a
cupcake or something
and so um and so we're going to do that
again
and so i'm pumped you're welcome to join
us um after this service to
um joining us there as well uh just
another quick reminder is that
next month is july and
during that time we do kind of allow and
ask brett to kind of take a break
there's just a lot of things sitting on
his shoulders
there's a lot of things that he it takes
care of and things like that so we do
invite guest speakers to come during
that month so you'll hear a lot of
different guest speakers during that
time
so just kind of know that for the month
of july it's just one of those things
that's just
a part of just our values as well for
just rest
um just taking a break from time to time
and just kind of know he's just going to
be on a little bit of a sabbatical when
it comes to that
so um let's see i think that's all
yeah i think it's all my announcements
so uh
so i'm gonna close this with a quick
prayer then we'll start worship
lord just thank you so much uh for
allowing us to be together
thank you for this opportunity thank you
for
this ability to be with all of these
people
thank you for being allowing us to come
to
together to sit
at this table to listen and to connect
with jesus
to learn from each other and i pray that
you open our hearts and minds
to what you have for us today uh be with
denise as she speaks with us
be with us as we open our hearts and
minds to your worship in christ i pray
amen amen
thanks donald if you guys
would like to stand um we're going to
do some music together and it's just an
opportunity for us
to recall the god that we believe
is here with us in our midst the god
that unites us together that is the
common thread
our beginning and our end um so
i just invite you to be a part of that
moment with us however you feel most
comfortable
um and i invite you also to
let your body be part of the worship as
well um
if you would like to clap or raise your
hands or if it's more comfortable for
you to sit and
just meditate on the lyrics too we just
want to invite you to this space
with us and as a community we are
worshiping together
it's not a show it's not a performance
this is
our time together to sing and um
paint the picture of who this god that
we believe in
what he's about and how he loves us so
well all right
you broke my chains of
seen in shame and you cover
me with grace
you mean my life with your holy
fire you cover me with
grace you are the head
that reaches out to save
i am set free
it is for freedom
that i am set free
you broke my chains of sin
and shame and you covered me
with grace
you mend my life with your holy
fire you cover me with grace
you are the hand that reaches out to
save
[Music]
it is for freedom
that i am set free
i am set free
i am serious
it is for freedom
that i am set free
and yes lord we are
grateful for your grace and
for your love
yes lord we are grateful
for your grace and for
your love sing that with us
yes lord we are grateful for
your grace and for your
love for time yes
lord we are grateful
for your grace and
[Music]
i am
it is for freedom
that i am set free
[Music]
it is for freedom that i
am set free
what can wash away
my sin nothing but the blood of
jesus what
can make me
[Music]
is the flow that
makes me white i so
know found
i know nothing but the blood of
[Music]
jesus
for my pardon for my pardon
this i see nothing but the blood of
jesus for
my cleansing this my plea
nothing but the blood of jesus
[Music]
i know nothing but the blood of
jesus
is all my open peace
nothing but the blood of
jesus this
is all my righteousness
nothing but the blood of
jesus and oh
precious is
[Music]
i nothing but the blood of
jesus
nothing but the blood of
[Music]
cause god is so
good
[Music]
is
see he answers he
answers prayer
he answers
prayers he
answers prayers
he saw
[Music]
to me
god you're so
good
[Music]
as we enter into our prayers of the
people i just want to
remind you if this is your first time or
um if you haven't been here in a while
we're just going to take a few minutes
to pray together for um people or
situations that might be
on your heart i'm going to open us up
with a short prayer and at the end of
each line it says we pray to you and if
you guys want to join in with me and say
that
phrase together i'll end that prayer and
then open it up for a couple minutes for
all of us to share
um if there's someone that's on your
heart that you know is in need of prayer
or um a situation a people group
something in our culture that we're
facing that you want to lift up go ahead
and just shout that out
and karen is going to be on our online
feed
looking if you are joining us online and
you would like to share
a prayer request online just type that
into the comments
and she will share that with us here in
this room
so we would love for you guys to engage
this time with us as well
virtually um and then at the end of our
time i'll wrap it up
with a prayer as well so um you guys
thank you for the the weeks that we have
done this in our past it's been such a
great opportunity for us to remember
that this worship time
is a communal service it's something
that we're entering into together
and um yeah i just encourage you to
to share what's on your heart but do
please just
remember to respect people's privacy as
well as we share
all right for this city of saxi texas
and for every city and community
and all of those who live in them we
pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us and the wisdom
and the will to conserve it we pray to
you
for those who travel on land sea and air
we pray to you for the sick
and the old for the widow and orphan for
the injured and suffering
we pray to you for the poor and
oppressed
the unemployed and destitute for
prisoners and captives and for all who
remember
and care for them we pray to you
lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us
and so we lift these names and
situations
up to you
[Music]
foreign
good job
[Music]
struggling with mental health
from online sarah
for these names and moments that we have
spoken aloud and for those that we have
kept in our hearts we pray to you that
they may have life and light healing and
hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
this is how i fight my battles
this is my battles
this is how
this is how i fight my battles
there's a table that you've prepared
for me
[Music]
in the presence of my
enemies
it's your body and blood you've shed for
me
this is how i fight my battles
[Music]
in the valley i know that you're with me
and surely your goodness
and mercy follow me
so my weapons are praising thanksgiving
this is how i fight my battles
[Music]
and i believe you overcome and
i will lift my song of
praise for all you've done
this is how i fight my battles
this is how
it may look like i'm surrounded but i'm
surrounded by you
this is how i fight my battles
it may look like i'm surrounded but i'm
surrounded by you
this is how i fight my battle
this is how i fight my battles
this is how i find my battles
this is how this is how i fight
my battle this is how i find my battles
this is how i fight my battles this
is how it may look
it may look like i'm surrounded but i'm
surrounded by you
this is how i fight my battle
this is how i fight my battles
this is how
this is how i find my battles
this is
i'm just reminded of that verse that
says you need only to be still and he
will fight for you jesus thank you
that we're not alone in our struggles
that you don't leave us to ourselves
but that you are present in every moment
you are there when we are alone you are
there when we're surrounded god
and you've been so faithful to carry us
through
every season every struggle
god would we invite you in would we be
looking for you would we be finding
your hand that's at work in our lives
and in our community
would we be quick to see you
and to recognize your movement
[Music]
would we be quick to feel your love and
to share it with the world around us
god help our eyes to be set on you in
your ways
help us to see ourselves the way that
you do
whole and complete lacking nothing
and god would we live into that
would we live into your goodness your
mercy your forgiveness
would we carry your love
we're so grateful for you so grateful
for this time together
grateful to share it it's in your name
that we ask
all these things amen
if you guys want to turn wave to the
people around you you can
see some more faces tonight so it's so
nice to
see smiles i love looking out and seeing
you guys y'all say hi to each other
all right um i get to just grab the mic
for a quick minute because i have the
privilege of introducing our guest
speaker tonight
i know um don was mentioning earlier
that we're really
trying to be intentional like we're a
new church and we sort of feel like the
rhythms that we set in place
now become norm for later on
so we're trying to start off on the
right foot of setting rhythms of rest
and that's honestly why last week
everyone was not here we were
encouraging everyone to go be with your
family take memorial day weekend
and be together and so we missed you and
it's super glad
or i'm super happy to be back together
but that's also why brett's not here
i think john don i think you're a month
ahead i think you were saying july
but it's june so but don is already in
july
he's like full on summer mode
you said july yeah well that's okay but
it's june
so yes june is the month that we're
trying to take space we encourage
not just brett to take space but all of
those of you who've been leading meetup
groups
and um you know ministry teams and stuff
like that we're trying to find ways to
build in space
so that we can avoid being totally burnt
out on the back end um
but we want those healthy rhythms in our
lives so tonight
denise would you mind coming up i have
the privilege of
introducing denise mason who is actually
the pastor of this
church that we meet in every week so yes
um i just want to tell a quick story
because
um when the table was first starting i
well actually karen and myself and
juanita johnson
um were we were scouring looking for
like
what's a location that could take us in
not just
begrudgingly but could take us
in in a way that we could celebrate one
another and
be in a space where we felt like it's
mutually beneficial
and we're both so happy to see the other
person thriving but we knew we would
need a
shared space location as or you know a
brand new church and
long story short um denise was not the
first
pastor that i emailed actually she
wasn't even the first of ten
um but between juanita and myself and
karen i mean we had reached out to
multiple
locations and crazy enough like
brett and i live what like two minutes
down the road it literally takes us two
minutes to get here
never once did i even i don't know why
it was just like all of a sudden one day
i'm sitting on my porch swing and
thought like i wonder
if that method is churched right down
from us would be an option
and so we sent denise an email or i sent
denise an email and heard back from her
quickly which i had gotten mostly radio
silence across the board from all
pastors that i had written before that
and not only did i just hear back from
her on email but we had a phone call and
i immediately
told brett like i called brett
afterwards i said brett
i just talked to the pastor at pleasant
valley and she actually sounds like she
wants
us there she's excited
about meeting us and the possibility of
partnering together and being able to
use their space
and i can't tell you just from that
first phone call i
still remember i'm sitting on a bench in
a dentist office talking to her
and from that first phone call till now
this woman has a
spirit of welcome and open invitation
like that is
just who she is i don't know those of
you who got to experience before covid
hour
was it christmas eve that we did
together a christmas eve service
and that's just does it not just ooze
out of her like
it just oozes out of her like this just
spirit of
welcome and you don't have to earn love
it's just here to be poured out
and i i just from the first time the
elder team got to meet with her
i mean i cannot tell you we were in a
fragile state
we were in a fragile place and her
affirmation
and ability to look us in the eye and
say guys i believe in what you're doing
and i want you to know it's the right
thing and
i will never forget those words coming
out of her mouth i don't know gary and
karen
but i those are your exact words and i
can say them
verbatim because they like it was like
they got etched on my heart at that
moment and
um so we're like we look up to her
i look up to her as someone that not
not just you know out of fear but of
love and respect
and um and i'm just grateful that you're
here
tonight with us so thank you so much yes
yeah we can switch on can i pray for you
before you start speaking
okay god we are so privileged to have
denise here
and um not just here with us tonight but
for the
spirit that she's created in this place
um and that she's helped to foster
long before we were ever here tonight
and god i just
am so grateful for the work you've done
in her and through her
and god i ask your blessing on it um
not just for those of us that are within
earshot of her tonight but
far beyond this place god i just ask
that you would continue to use her
i just think of that scripture that
talks about john the baptist that he was
a light that people enjoyed for the
season that you had him on the planet
and
i think of denise that way she's a light
that we get to sit
and um be pointed towards the true light
of christ
so god i just um bless her and thank you
for her
and we open our hearts and ears for what
you want to speak to us tonight it's in
your name that we pray
amen thank you thank you
am i on okay let me turn myself on now
am i on
the green light's on and it says it's am
i oh now i'm on yeah
thank you well first off let me just say
that
i am kind of a little bit i feel like
that was just the most wonderful welcome
ever and i will tell you that um
i get a lot of emails um asking me lots
of things through the website
and i happened to be down in houston
with um
our administrative assistant who was
having chemo at the time down at md
anderson
when i got maggie's email and most of
the time i get these emails and i'm like
yeah yeah we'll get back to them
but something in that moment said to me
you need to call her so you might have
been in a dentist office i was in a
chemo place and
in md anderson when i called you back i
called you within minutes of getting
your email
because god said to me you need to do
this and i truly believe and i want to
tell you all this i truly believe
that you were meant to come here and i'm
so glad i'm so glad
that you are here i believe so totally
in what you are about and i believe that
god is going to do mighty things through
you and so i'm so
very grateful that you're here but i'm
grateful that brett asked me to come
and speak to you tonight um he actually
texted me a few minutes ago
on my watch i just saw it and so thank
you brett
so i don't know um i wanted to start by
reading the scripture that i've chosen
for tonight
this is kind of a long scripture so stay
with me
it's from first samuel it's verses
i'm sorry chapter 15 started at verse 34
and go through 16
13. so like i said it's long but here we
go
then samuel went to rama and saul went
up to his house in gibea of saul
samuel did not see saul again until the
day of his death but samuel grieved over
saul
and the lord was sorry that he had made
saul king
over israel the lord said to samuel how
long will you grieve over saul i
i have rejected him from being king over
israel
fill your horn with oil and set out i
will send you to jesse the bethlehemite
for i provided for myself a king
among his sons samuel said how can i go
if
saul hears of it he'll kill me and the
lord said
take a heifer with you and say i've come
to sacrifice
to the lord invite jesse to the
sacrifice and i will show you what you
shall do when you shall anoint for me
the one i name to you samuel did what
the lord commanded and came to bethlehem
the elders of the city came out to meet
him trembling and said
do you come peaceably he said peaceably
i have come to sacrifice to the lord
sanctify yourselves and come with me to
the sacrifice
and he sanctified jesse and his sons and
invited them to the sacrifice
when they came samuel looked at eliab
and thought
surely the lord's anointed us now before
the lord
but the lord said to samuel do not look
upon his appearance
or upon his height or stature because i
have rejected him
for the lord does not see as mortal see
they look on the outward appearance
but the lord looks on the heart
then jesse called abina abinadab
and made him pass before samuel he said
neither has the lord chosen this one
then jesse made shama pass by and he
said neither has the lord chosen this
one
and jesse made seven of his sons pass
before samuel and samuel said to jesse
the lord has not chosen any of these
samuel said to jesse are all your sons
here
and he said the remains yet the youngest
but he's keeping the sheep
and samuel said to jesse send and bring
him
for we will not sit down until he comes
here
so he sent and brought him in now he was
ruddy
with beautiful eyes and was handsome and
the lord said
rise and anoint him for he
is the one then samuel took the horn of
oil and anointed him in the presence of
his brothers
and the spirit of the lord came mightily
upon david from that day forward
samuel then set out and went to ramah
this is god's word for god's people
would you join me in prayer
come holy spirit may the words of my
mouth and the meditations of our hearts
be acceptable in your sight for you are
our rock
and our redeemer amen
so i well remember the day that i
received my very first appointment as a
pastor
it was pretty surreal because all of a
sudden i was no longer
the questioner seeking answers from
those in authority i was the one given
the authority
i was the person that everyone else
looked to for answers on all things
spiritual and i have to tell you it was
a little terrifying
because although i now had the title of
reverend
i was still me i may have had the title
but
i didn't feel like a pastor
that is until my first social outing
with some of my congregants
because it seemed like every time
someone opened their mouth to say
anything they would say oh i'm so sorry
pastor
i sort of should have said shoot or i
should have said darn it
i'm so sorry it was as if they believed
that a foul word had never come out of
my mouth
and or or that like swearing in front of
a pastor was like
commensurate to putting a crucifix in
front of a vampire you know like a
disintegrate or something and even
though i've taught many a lesson since
on the true meaning of the second
commandment thou shalt not take the lord
of the name of the lord thy god in vain
well it still seems that to this day
people feel the need to apologize to me
when they swear it's like the moment i
received the title of
was taken out of the box i was in and
put into another
box a box that says all pastors act in a
certain manner
all pastors expect certain conduct and
above all
pastors are the police of everything
that we
well shall we say might be slightly
indelicate
i find that box slightly restrictive
but i realize that no one is maliciously
putting me in that box
i mean it just seems to be a universal
trait
of humans to try and fit people into
certain categories
or or boxes now psychologist tells us
that
tell us that over the eons humans found
categorizing people into certain
stereotypes or boxes helped
simplify our social world by reducing
the amount of processing or
thinking we have to do when we meet a
new person
see if we can quickly put them into a
category or identify who another person
is by using a few visual clues
well ostensibly we're less likely to
commit
terrible social faux pas or put
ourselves into situations that could be
dangerous
now i think that all we are who are here
this evening
are very well aware of the harmful and
frankly horrific injustice that is
perpetuated as a result of
placing people into boxes based on race
or
gender or ethnicity or sexual preference
and i pray that we actively reject those
boxes at every turn
but for the most part those negative
stereotypes are fairly
easily noticed right and are pointed out
to us what we do with that is up to us
but much harder to spot
are the millions of little boxes that we
place people
in every day things we don't consider
racist or sexist or bad in some way
they're just assumptions that we base on
our experiences or
our understanding of how the world works
or the common experiences of our culture
of our faith or
group or nation or whatever it might be
these things might be like all tall
people are good at basketball
all old people are wise and conversely
young people know nothing
all new yorkers are rude
canadians are very nice
this younger generation has no moral
compass
blondes are ditzy redheads have terrible
tempers
and we're not going there short men have
napoleon complexes on
and on it goes now not all of us use
these boxes but i venture to guess
that we all use some boxes
we all have certain ingrained beliefs
about others based on
their looks or occupation or whatever it
is
now this is certainly the case in our
text for today
the story of god choosing david
to be the king of israel see that tells
us that
god sends samuel to with jesse the
bethlehemite
for god says i've provided for myself a
king
from among his sons so sam
is off to bethlehem and when he gets
there he invites jesse and his sons to
come to a sacrifice
now this isn't just an invitation to
come and watch samuel sacrifice a heifer
now this this is an invitation to come
and participate in worshipping
and then eat that heifer that was
sacrificed so it's an invitation to a
feast you see
so of course jesse agrees he comes and
when they all get there
samuel sees the oldest son eliab
now eliab must have been a looker he
must have been tall
he was strong and hearty because samuel
immediately assumes that he is the one
after all he he fits all the criteria
that you would think a king needs
but god says nope it's not him
now samuel don't judge him on his looks
or his height or his muscles
because he's not the one i choose see i
don't see
people the way mortals see people you
all see what's on the outside but i see
what's on the
inside i see their heart
so eliab is rejected and next comes
abinadab who is also rejected and i
might say i'm very thankful for that
just based
purely on the pronunciation of his name
alone
then comes shema whose rejection is
followed by the rejection of four
other unnamed brothers
now samuel might must have been getting
a little concerned at this point because
none of these were the ones that god had
chosen
are you sure these are all your sons
samuel says
to jesse and jesse replies well there is
one more but you know he's just a kid
he's out watching the sheep in other
words
you don't really want him i mean he
didn't really have the right
stuff if you know what i mean
now samuel seems a tad exasperated here
and he says look send somebody to get
him because we're not going to sit down
and eat
until he gets here now realistically it
would have taken a couple hours for them
to go out and get david and bring him
back
and so you can kind of imagine this
group sitting around
and making small talk while their
stomachs are growling smelling this meat
but he finally makes it in and when
david stands there we're told god says
to samuel
rise and anoint him for he is
the one god has made a choice
and the person god chose
would have been voted least likely to
succeed
god chooses the daydream head
play on his harp in the fields
while he's watching the sheep the one
whose
brothers we later find out well have no
time for
the one whose own father thought he was
completely out of the running
god chooses the annoying little brother
the one no one else would have chosen
because the scripture says god does not
see as mortals
see they look on the outward appearance
but god
looks on the heart in other words you
see god
sees what we cannot possibly see god
sees the possibilities and they're
infinite
now the story of david's anointing is
one that
challenges us to examine the boxes we
place other people in
just limiting our expectations of others
based on what they look like
their age where they come from their
gender their sexual preference
or a myriad of other things it's an
important message for us to hear
but just underneath this message
is another message that is equally as
profound
a message that tells us to examine not
only the box we place
others in but examine both the box we
may place ourselves in
and the box we may place god
in see it tells us to let go of any
preconceived notions of who we believe
god can and will use and any assumptions
we might have about
who and why god chooses
see the story it's similar to so many
other stories in the bible
by uh stories that tells us about how
consistently
picks those who seem to be at best
nobodies and
at worst nobody's with pretty bad
problems
i mean people like joseph and moses
isaiah mary peter
paul and we might ask ourselves
why them why were they chosen
i mean we're told god looks on the heart
but
was joseph the annoying braggart
moses the murderer mary
the teenager peter the lowly fisherman
and paul the former terrorists
terrorists
were those the only people god could
find with good hearts
and was david a simple shepherd boy
god chose to be king was he the only
person in the entire kingdom with a good
heart
the answer according to this story is
no see if we look really closely
that this story reveals something very
interesting
david the greatest king of israel the
one
called a man after god's own heart
the one who built the city of jerusalem
and out of whose lineage
the people were promised a messiah that
david
was not god's plan a
see this story tells us that god's plan
a
was soul god
chose saul but apparently
saul had trouble believing it
now you may or may not be familiar with
saul's story but
suffice to say that saul constantly
doubted god's choice
and so when things got tough well saul
did things his own way
you know he was from the smallest tribe
and the smallest and most humbling clan
among that tribe and really he was
nothing more than just a big guy out
looking for his dad's donkeys when he
happened to stumble upon samuel
just at the right time that samuel was
looking for a king
and because of that you see he didn't
think he was good enough
see he assumed he knew what box he
should be
in and this wasn't it
and unfortunately he lived up to that
assumption
see so much so that our text tells us i
don't know if you heard this but our
text
tells us that god was sorry
that he had made saul king did you hear
that god
was sorry that he had made saul king
now did god
choose the wrong person here
or did that person fail to believe that
god is bigger than any box
we might think we belong in and even
more importantly bigger than any box we
might think
god belongs in
see the text tells us that god looks at
the heart
so if god chose saul he had to have seen
a good heart in him
god saw the possibilities of saul but
saul
mired in his own assumptions about
himself well he closed his mind
and his heart to the possibilities of
god
working in and through him despite
chance after chance and encouragement
and nourishment from god
saul's failure to trust that god
could and would do what god had promised
well it limited what god could and would
have done through him
god sees the heart god
sees the possibility but the heart
has to trust god to do what we cannot
fathom doing on our own
see the difference between saul's heart
and david's heart
well it wasn't that saul was a sinner
and
david was a saint we know that's not
true
david was a very flawed individual just
as flawed as
saul but unlike saul
david believed that god could take
a lowly shepherd boy and make him into a
king
david believed that with god the
possibilities are endless
he may not have been plan a but he knew
that god
was not limited by any one plan
see god is a god of limitless plans
looking for people who are willing to
step out of their box
and trust that god can make
that which seems improbable probable
that which seems impossible possible
now you may not know this but for much
of my adult life i
was a stay-at-home mom to five kids
although i'll tell you i was a strong
feminist and still am
the moment i held my first child in my
arms and looked into his eyes i knew i
wanted to spend every waking moment
and so my husband and i made the
decision that i would stay home
and it's a decision i don't regret one
bit
but as my children grew older and began
leaving home i started to get really
afraid
i mean what was i going to do after all
my kids were gone
i knew i wasn't really qualified to do
anything i mean yeah well i knew how to
take care of kids and i knew how to cook
although that
skill is somewhat up for debate yes i
could pack up a house and move at the
whim of my husband's job and sure i
could clean a house like a champ
and paint walls and fix toilets but
in my mind that was pretty much nothing
and as much on to greater things while i
stood in the background i was so
very proud of them yet worried that my
purpose
life was over
it was about this time that i joined a
bible study
one that eventually turned into a
covenant bible study of about eight
women
now i had been in many bible studies in
the past and i actually was kicked out
of
two community bible studies but that's a
story for a different time
i even led a few bible studies but there
was something about this study or
of women that was special
maybe it was because they allowed me to
dig deeply in my
into my face questions
that plagued me or maybe it was the
support that they
offered me during some very difficult
times in my life
but whatever it was i found myself
closer to god
than i had ever been before
but with this closeness did not come
easiness
in fact i felt very restless i had this
constant
yearning for something but i didn't know
what
so i just sat on it
didn't know what to do until one day
one of the women in the group who
happened to be the associate pastor at
the
church i was excuse me attending
said to me maybe you have a call to
pastoral ministry
well i remember going home that night
and thinking oh yeah right
god wants me to be a pastor get real
i'm the least qualified person ever i
have not
worked outside the home i have no
special gifts or talents i
i'm not the kind of person god would
call i'm stubborn
i question everything i have no great
insight i'm
frankly pretty awkward in front of
others i have a.d.d
that shout squirrel at the tune moments
and frankly my experiences in the church
had not made me the greatest fan
of the church now i'm unsure i thought
what god
might want from me but this can't be it
because i knew what box i fit in
and my box wasn't anywhere big enough
for that
now fast forward 11 years and i stand
before you
this evening i know without a shadow of
a doubt
that i do not have the skills or the
talent
to do what i do on my own
i know likely person for god to have
picked
to do this but i also know one other
thing
god chose me god chose me and asked me
to trust enough to step outside the box
i thought i belonged in god chose me
just as god chooses you
view god chooses
you i can't tell you what god
chooses you to do but i can tell you
that god
chooses you to do the work of the
kingdom
in this world
you may be sitting here this evening
thinking you're the last person
the least qualified the most awkward or
whatever
thing it is that defines the box that
you're sitting in
you may be thinking that your past
somehow how disqualifies you or
your present circumstances are too
complicated or
they limit you in some way but i want
you to know this
god sees your heart
and it is good god sees your heart and
it is good
god sees the possibilities and you god
great things that god can accomplish
through you and god is looking for you
to believe
that too god is looking for you to
believe that you're a part of the plan
whether that's plan a b c d
or z is looking for you
to trust trust enough to to let go of
what you think
you can do let go of
can or will do to open your heart
and your mind to what god can do
through you
look neither you nor i or david
we're not giant slayers or mighty kings
but then again neither was david
he was just a simple shepherd boy
his accomplishments were not his own
they were god's accomplishments
and the same god seeks to accomplish
mighty things through you and through me
so this evening i invite each of you to
throw away those boxes
throw away whatever box you are sitting
in that you think defines you
let go and trust
give your entire heart to god
and watch and see what god
can and will do
amen would you pray with me
loving and most gracious god
we like to define ourselves and in doing
so we
limit what you can do god i know that
you
have chosen everyone who is here today
and i know you can do mighty things i
pray that you will help each of us open
our hearts to that
to let go and allow you to do
mighty and great things in us and
through us
it's in the name of jesus the christ
that we ask all these things
amen
thank you so much denise we are going to
uh
close out with a song called oceans um
you guys might have heard it before but
what stood out to me
this week when denise told us what she
was planning to be talking about were
these lyrics um
i just i wonder if for you they will
resonate with this message that she's
been sharing with us
where we finally let go and
invite jesus to take us wherever he's
planning to take us
and to stop limiting ourselves to stop
looking at all the borders and instead
look at the boundlessness of god
and um and follow him
so you guys um sing along
if you know it and um listen to the
words
and let them resonate inside of us
you call me out upon the waters
the greater known
where feet may fail
and there i find you in the mystery
in oceans deep
my faith will stand
and i will call upon your name
and keep my eyes above the waves
when oceans rise my soul will rest in
your
embrace for i am
yours and you are my
your grace abounds in deepest waters
your sovereign head
will be my guide
[Music]
you've never failed and you won't start
now
and i will call upon your name
and keep my eyes above the waves
[Music]
foreign
oh you
[Music]
are
spirit leave me
[Music]
take me deeper than my fear
could ever wander and my faith will be
made stronger in the presence of
my savior spirit
lead me where my trust is without
borders
let me walk upon the waters
wherever you would call me
take me deeper than my feet
could ever wander and my faith will be
made stronger in the presence of
my saints think that one more time
spirit
lead me where my trust is without
borders
let me walk upon the waters
wherever you would call me
and take me deeper than my feet could
ever
wander and my faith would be made
stronger
in the presence of my savior
[Music]
and i will call upon your name
and keep my eyes above the waves
when oceans rise my soul
will rest in your embrace
for i am yours
and you are my
you are mine
[Music]
let's pray
lord just thank you so much for
just being able to um
allow us to be together to hear
just where you have us i pray that you
help us to see just those
boundaries those barriers those boxes
that we're in
the things that you are calling us to do
maybe the fear that we have that are
just holding us back
i pray you give us strength and courage
to go out
and to
do what you're calling us to do and be
jesus to other people
and christ's name i pray amen
okay couple quick announcements
okay so um i mentioned before at the end
of the service
um we are having just a quick get
together at hat creek
burger i said it right
okay so um that's gonna be here in saxi
so um after service if you want to meet
us over there
just for just a quick meal be able to
you know get to know each other and
everything like that they'll be
fantastic a couple other things if
you're a visitor we'd like to know
who you are um and we do have some
visitor cards outside in the foyer if
you wouldn't mind just kind of filling
one of those out for us so we just kind
of know
um just who you are would love to send
you a quick little message
and also if um anything that we have
shared with you today
um just kind of resonates with you um we
welcome you
guys to give you can of course use the
envelopes on the outside in front you
can also give
as well online and then just real quick
i want to launch this off into a thought
because i'm sitting here thinking
through everything that denise has
shared with us tonight
i also want to just hear about
you know the song that we're just saying
um
this this song specifically was
important to me as i was trying to just
figure out
me personally just different things in
my life
of should i be okay
with my queerness or should i be okay
being as straight as i possibly could
and those boxes and barriers were just
things i had been taught all my entire
life about what it means to be queer
and what it means to be gay and just
trying to follow
those rules routines and everything that
goes along with it and just white
knuckle my faith
the entire time and it was scary scary
it was scary to
walk out into the waters as it were so
this was a prayer
that that was said that i said over and
over just trying to figure it out
not knowing um and i say and what i said
the beginning
about this being pride month i know that
pride is one of those things that we
kind of talk about at least says
queer people like oh my gosh it's pride
yeah it's a big party
even if you're not you have your own set
of things
that you wrestle with that you carry
with you
um that you're not sure what it is those
boundaries those boxes
and things like that and that's what
this whole entire thing is it doesn't
matter
what it is so pray that you
that this if you can accept the fact
that there's queer people in your life
you can accept we can accept everything
about you
everything because we love you period it
doesn't matter
it doesn't matter so anyway so go forth
we love you and you guys